so a bunch of students tore down a
Confederate monument at UNC Chapel Hill
this week and the media calls these
people protestors but they really are
just vandals and criminals whatever you
think about the Confederacy
it is felony vandalism to destroy a
statue like that but this is the
precedent that we've set over the past
few years it's a very dangerous
precedent in my view where if you don't
like a statue well then go ahead and
just tear it down the law is gonna step
to the side and allow felony destruction
of property to occur without doing
anything about it now that said I have
no problem with this specific monument
coming down per se
III think this we can't lump all
Confederate monuments together
not all Confederate monuments are are
equal this one was erected in I believe
1918 or somewhere around there and it
was clear from the beginning that it was
associated with white supremacy so yeah
take it down now I still don't think
that a school should stand by and let
students do it themselves because that's
a crime and is you can't have that kind
of chaos and you can't allow students to
just go well I don't like this and so
they they take they take it down and I
still don't think we can lump all
Confederate monuments together I think
we have to take it on a case-by-case
basis
and there are several problems with the
precedent that we're setting here and
that has been said over the last couple
of years when it comes to these
monuments not the least of which is is
how unevenly the precedent is applied
there are many monuments in America that
that may be reasonably considered
offensive because they commemorate bad
people or they commemorate people who
represented bad things or both in some
cases and the argument against
Confederate monuments I guess is that
they fought for a bad thing now which is
slavery now I'm I'm of course everyone
agrees in modern America that slavery is
a bad thing not everyone agrees from a
historical perspective that it's
necessarily exactly accurate to say that
the Confederates fought primarily for
slavery I'm not gonna really get into a
discussion it's a different discussion
but the real causes of the Civil War and
everything that is a multi-faceted
discussion I think anyone who's done
even a little bit of reading understands
that it's it's it's certainly not it's
at least not quite as simple as that now
there are those who argue that it was
straightforwardly a war over slavery
others will point out that slavery was
only turned into the reason for the war
about midway through it was a political
decision made by Lincoln when he was
when he began to see that Europe may may
come to the aid of the south and he saw
that and that's when the Emancipation
Proclamation came and Emancipation
Proclamation was a political document
that had no actual effect and did
nothing at all except politically
because it was it was written
specifically to free slaves in the
States that Lincoln no had no longer had
any control over while allowing state
while allowing states that he did
control to keep their slaves so again it
was just a political document and and
this this idea that it was a war over
slavery something happened halfway
through going into the war Lincoln made
it clear that he did not want to fight a
war over slavery if he could keep the
Union together and keep slavery he would
do that he also made it clear in while
he was running for president that he did
not believe in equality for black and
white people he did not believe that
black people were equal to white people
so he was a racism stuff now all of
these things are you know these are all
relevant but
put all that to the side what I what I
don't think can be denied is that
several of the men who've had their
monuments torn down especially robert e
lee's Stonewall Jackson some others
these particular men let's just talk
about Jackson and Lee for say these were
men of high moral character and great
personal courage who did not themselves
believe that they were fighting for
slavery
both men opposed slavery personally as
did plenty of other southerners though I
think Lee's wife did own slaves which is
true general Grant's wife also owned
slaves you saw that on the north as well
which is another reason which is another
complicating factor when you think about
well where did the people and no did the
people in the North the northern
soldiers especially did they think that
they were marching down into the south
to fight against slavery and I think the
answer in most cases is no and we kind
of can see that the answer is no because
some of their generals actually owned
slaves but the point is that they you
know guys like Jackson Lee they felt
obliged to fight on the side of their
home states you can say that they were
wrong about that that they were mistaken
they made the wrong choice they were
blinded by loyalty to families and homes
and whatever but if you paint them all
as slobbering racists or if you suggest
that Jackson and Lee were fighting
because they really wanted to keep black
people enslaved well then it's gonna be
clear that you've just never read a
history book because that's that's just
that's just not said accurate the
interesting thing is that both Lee and
Jackson were admired by the north and
the south during the time of the Civil
War the men who marched down into
Virginia to kill Confederates still had
a greater respect for some of the
Confederate officers than we do today
which is kind of interesting I mean
these were you know these guys had a
much greater reason to hate those men
than we do and yet they didn't hate them
nearly as much and I do think when
you're looking at a guy like Robert Lee
you you do have to look within the
context of the time this was a war hero
a man that was respected as I said
across the country before the Civil War
the federal government comes to him and
wants him to put it plots to put him in
charge of the army but from Lee's
perspective as a Virginia man if he does
that even though he opposed secession
and he was morally opposed to slavery
but if he if he were to take this job
offer from the federal government it
means that he will be leading troops
into his home state into his home taking
up arms against his friends neighbors
and even his own sons so for him it's a
choice between the federal government or
his family and his home and his country
now what we have to understand is that
back in those days especially in the
south you consider when you talked about
your country when a guy said my country
what he meant most of the time was his
state in the early days of of the United
States people especially in the south
identified much more with their state
than they did with the country they saw
the country as this collection of States
but they looked at their state as their
actual home in their country and what
they were most loyal to we don't look at
it like that now but it's kind of hard
to say they were wrong for seeing it
that way
um I I would argue that they were
actually much more in the spirit of what
was intended when the country was
founded where it was never really
intended that people would necessarily
identify with the federal government or
have any great loyalty to it people were
more loyal to their actual homes because
they were tied to their homes they were
tied to the land they were you know we
didn't they didn't have all the tech now
they have radios and Internet and
everything where they could kind of
connect with everyone across the country
they just had their home in their land
and their farms and their families
that's all they had and that's what they
were loyal to and that's what guys like
so someone like Robert Ely he had to
make that choice between in his mind it
was between his home and the federal
government he chose his home and
then he proceeded to fight with great
brilliance and dignity always
outnumbered always out manned always
outgunned and yet winning battle after
battle with courage and tenacity and
that's why he has monuments ok the fact
that the Confederacy was a slaveholding
country is a very serious moral problem
and yes he is stained by it inevitably
but Thomas Jefferson actually owned
slaves personally hundreds of them
Thomas Jefferson owned hundreds of
humans he owned people and yet most of
us can still admire the great things
that he did and honor him for those for
the rete for those regions for the great
things that he did even aside from the
very dark evil that he was personally
and directly involved in
so what I'm saying is my opinion on
Confederate statues is that some of them
are worth keeping up some of them are
not and it really just depends on the
situation but I do think we need to try
to develop a little bit of a more
nuanced and mature and historically
accurate perspective on that period in
our history which I think many of us
simply don't have be that as it may
the argument is that all of these
monuments must come down because the
monuments represents slavery whether or
not the individuals who actually fought
for the south meant to or wanted to
personally fight for slavery and many of
them had no such intention but that's
the art so we've established the
precedent that people who are on the
wrong historical side of a grave moral
issue even indirectly on its side cannot
have monuments that appears to be that's
what we're saying when it comes to the
Confederate thing well then we have to
ask what about what about people who
were personally morally depraved rotten
and evil yet or on the right side of
some issue I think we can agree or
should agree that they don't deserve
monuments either
we would all be kind of upset if animal
rights activists erected a monument to
Adolf Hitler on the basis that Adolf
Hitler was himself a proponent of animal
rights which he was or in or
environmentalism or whatever so it seems
that the precedent is that only decent
people who fought for decent things can
have statutes
here's my problem
it has been open season on the indecent
and offensive monuments only so long as
those are monuments to 19th century
white guys from the American South that
to me seems way too selective if we're
gonna do this thing if we're really
gonna start purging the offensive
monuments on the basis that I've just
mentioned here then I think it had we
have to we have to go we have to do it
all it doesn't make sense to focus
especially and only on these Confederate
monuments makes no sense the Selective
if we do it so selectively then the
Selective nature of this purging will
lead people myself included to suspect
that there is a specifically left-wing
ideological motivation behind this
outcry against statues and it actually
has very little to do with with with
slavery or racism or anything
if it's not ideological if our modern
sensibilities simply will not tolerate
statues that commemorate problematic
figures of any sort then I think it
doesn't make any sense that the outrage
has not extended beyond Confederate
soldiers you know many people in the
South feel that this is an attack on
their heritage and their history if it's
not that if it's not an attack on their
heritage in the history if it's really
just a movement against evils like
racism and slavery then all of the
statues associated with evil should come
down
if these are the only ones that come
down then I think people from the South
that are upset about this because they
feel like their heritage and history is
being attacked I think they're
vindicated there they have every right
to be upset and their suspicions have
been vindicated and confirmed if there's
if there's are the only statues that
come down if we're looking to be
consistent then we have to go for all
the offensive statues or we go for none
of them and just let them all stay up I
think that's kind of the way you know
that's the way we have to we have to
look at if we are this is not what about
ISM okay this is just simply a matter of
consistently applying a principle
and I think a lot of the time people are
I do I get accused of what about ISM
other your what you know that's anytime
something is going on and you come along
and you say well yeah but what about
there's not always a problem but
sometimes it makes sense to say what
about because what you're the the
message the argument you're making is
okay let's extend this principle let's
consistently apply the principle and
when a principle is only being applied
over here but not over here I think it
is perfectly reasonable to come and say
what about over here
let's take that principle and extend it
and if you don't want to extend that
principle across the board well then
there's something wrong with the
principle and we need to reevaluate
that's the point of the what about
argument is what we're trying to do is
we're trying to establish it if you
don't want to consistently apply the
principle there's something wrong with
the principle we need to throw it out or
we need to consistently apply it so
let's sum let's go over a few other
offensive monuments and statues that if
we are consistently applying the
principle should also come down number
one there is the monument to child sex
predator Harvey Milk in San Francisco
now there are a few monuments to Harvey
Milk in San Francisco and I think across
the country there are there even streets
named after him and schools and there's
a naval ship named after him for some
damn reason I don't know why he's got
he's got his own naval ship and and he
has his own postage stamps okay he's gay
this guy's all over the place I don't
advocate for tearing down the schools
just because they have his name or the
or and I don't advocate for for
demolishing the naval ship I think those
can just be renamed the posters postage
stamps can be burned but the monuments
must come down
Harvey Milk is despite what you may have
heard in Hollywood this is not a civil
rights hero this is not a hero of any
kind all he did this is what he
accomplished with his life is he was
attracted to other men and he was
elected to public office that was his
whole achievement is his own political
advancement that's what he did okay that
was his one achievement but I don't I
don't see how that minor political
achievement
outweighs the fact that Harvey Milk was
a pederasty who preyed upon
drug-addicted boys
a quote from one of his friends that is
is instructive because even his spreads
even the people that knew him don't deny
this fact one of his friends said that
he had a penchant for young Waifs with
drug abuse problems let's be more
specific about this the young Waifs were
minors Runaways and drug addicts who
came to milk looking for a mentor or
father figure and instead they were
groomed to be milks sex toys essential
at least to have two of his victims
later went on to commit suicide okay
was a deeply evil man he contributed
nothing of value to society
he left misery and suicide in his wake
he preyed upon drug addicts and runaways
and he used their helplessness and their
vulnerability as a means to satisfy his
own sexual desires it that's that's what
he was he was murdered not he he was
murdered by a fellow Democrat that
doesn't make him a martyr
just because I'm sorry that that he was
killed that doesn't change anything
about this because the guys killed
doesn't make him a martyr doesn't make
him a hero doesn't make him a saint
you're not automatically canonized just
because you were killed doesn't change
the fact that he was a Petrus who preyed
upon you no 15 year old boys who were
Runaways and drug addicts and were
confused and lonely that's what he liked
to do that's how he got his his you know
that's how he he fulfilled his sexual
urges doesn't change that the fact that
he was killed doesn't change he was
still a deeply evil man and he does not
deserve to be remembered or commemorated
or honored at all not at all
and in fact
I don't know what the what the law was
back then but according to the law as a
Californian now if he were if he were
alive today he'd be going to jail for
what he did with these boys
number two there is a bust of Bill
Clinton in Little Rock Arkansas I think
also needs to come down Bill Clinton has
been credibly accused of rape assault
harassment multiple times
Juanita Broderick's story about Clinton
is horrifying I think most of us know it
by now but it's bears repeating
according to her she was lured to his
hotel room
where he proceeded to forcibly pin her
down on the bed while she pleaded with
him to stop and he raped her allegedly
this was forcible violent rape
not even a you know
a thing where some of the stuff you see
in Hollywood were basically Clinton
promised to advance her political career
as she slept with him and so she did it
and then she regretted it you know
wasn't it wasn't that kind of thing this
was pinned her down on the bed she's
pleading with him to stop she's saying
no no and he rapes her
the kind of thing that would put most
people in prison for a long time but
instead Bill Clinton went to the White
House and there are many other stories
of abuse all of them from people who are
far more credible than Clinton himself
and and and almost all these stories
follow the same pattern they sound very
similar they're very consistent and the
people that have been telling these
stories about Clinton have been telling
the same story for years they haven't
changed it so that's what makes them
credible and yet this guy has a statue
in Arkansas I think it needs to come
down number three there's a statue of a
mass murderer Vladimir Lenin in in
Seattle now this statue I believe is
privately owned it's on private property
I would not support destroying private
property but the statue toppling mobs
don't seem to mind destroying things
that don't belong to them so I'm trying
to figure out why they haven't gone
after this one yet I'm not saying that
they should as I said all these things
should be done legally should be taken
down legally but it's just interesting
that they haven't set their sights on
this yet Lenin was a was a Marxist
revolutionary who founded the the the
tyrannical Soviet state which would then
proceed to murder imprison starve and
slave tens of millions of people over
the course of the 20th century hundreds
of millions of people for a while on the
left there was a there was a an effort
and I think there still is an effort to
separate Lenin from Stalin and to say
well Stalin was the butcher and even
though there are still some people who
in fact we talked about a couple weeks
ago there was a poll done among
Millennials and a certain not that small
percentage of Millennials actually
admire Stalin they think he was an
admirable guy so even Stalin is but but
I I think among a lot of liberals there
has been historically an attempt to
separate Lennon from Stalin say well
Stalin was the butcher and Lenin was
just a fighter for Marxist ideals they
were both butchers although Lenin was a
a fighter for Marxist ideals and that
should tell you something about Marxist
ideals that he was a butcher and yet was
also consistently a fighter for those
ideals because they are terrible and
morally depraved ideals
that was that was that was Lenin so that
needs to come down number three or four
we outnumber number four I think there's
a bust of you Genest Margaret Sanger in
the National Portrait Institute now
Margaret Sanger of course is the and
this bust is part of their their civil
rights exhibit to make it even worse
part of their civil rights exhibit
and then the the National Portrait
Institute is run by the Smithsonian
Smith Smith Smithsonian Smithsonian I
can't speak anyway so it's part of their
their civil rights exhibit Margaret
Sanger obviously the founder of Planned
Parenthood she once proudly spoke to the
KKK and it is true maybe you've seen
that picture online of Margaret Sanger
standing up in front of a bunch of
hooded KKK members and giving a speech
that photo is fake it's it's it's
Photoshop not a real photo but she did
actually speak to the KKK she spoke to a
group of female KKK members she was a
proponent of the eugenics movement and
the eugenics movement was which was
which was popular in the early 20th
century the eugenics movement was and is
all about ridding society of the
undesirable classes through forced
sterilization and abortion and other
methods
now Sanger's apologists will will will
say that she was not a racist and that
she she wasn't looking to specifically
annihilate the black race instead she
was looking to just get rid of poor
people and especially people with mental
disabilities regardless of the race and
and that's that's true I that doesn't
make her any better she's still that's
not that's it that's a heck of a defense
isn't it but I think it's interesting
I've actually seen there's a certain
quote from Margaret Sanger that her
defenders will cite in order to defend
her against racism charges and I want to
read this quote to you this is her
talking to a group of black pastors
and this is what she said
she said the most successful educational
approach to the Negro is through a
religious appeal we don't want the word
to get out that we want to exterminate
the Negro population and the minister is
the man who can straighten out the idea
if it ever occurs to any of their more
rebellious members now
sure that her statement about educating
quote rebellious Negroes does much to
debunk the racism charges I don't think
it does but I do know that she
explicitly desired to eradicate the
undesirables and then the organization
that she founded which was later known
as Planned Parenthood
though at the time when she found it I
think was called the birth control
League or something like that that
organization would then go on to
actually eradicate over 7 million
undesirables according to her I don't
think that's a coincidence
you see I think
she had this idea and then the
organization founded one went on to
carry out that idea
praying especially on minority neighbor
neighborhoods and killing a
disproportionate number of black babies
that's not a coincidence
now ironically the this bust of Margaret
Sanger has been defended the person who
runs the National Portrait astir
defended it on the grounds that her
racist views mirrored her time so they
were you know part of the historical
context and also the National Portrait
Institute said that well the the effort
to remove the bust is really part of an
ideologically motivated campaign and the
backlash against the various monuments
to Harvey Milk has also been blocked on
the basis that while you're only trying
to tear those down and you only want to
get rid of those because you're anti-gay
but these are exactly the arguments that
defenders of Confederate statues make
it's exact same argument
what they'll say is that the troubling
aspects of the Confederacy must be seen
within their historical context and
they'll also say that the effort to wipe
these statues out is more political than
it is ethical
now it would seem to me that in the
interests of integrity and consistency
we must
we must decide
if we're going to apply that
consistently or not
are we going to tear down all of the
problematic statues or none of them to
focus on just one sort of problematic
statue and to ignore the the the
monuments that enshrine other kinds of
historical evil or other historically
evil characters to do that is to
basically admit that the attack on
Confederate statues is really nothing
more than a political stunt
so we just have to make up our mind
that's the point
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed